hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
I'm just checking in
checking in on you how's it going how
are you
how are you I'm in Washington DC
with all these [__] khaki panted
people
everyone here is a lobbyist
um
it's a very strange part of the country
you know what I mean it's just uh it's
it's like
it's like La well like nobody's from
here I feel
you know and it's everybody like uh it's
just a lot of people young people
walking around with their shirts tucked
into their pants
[Music]
[Laughter]
experience
life post crunch once grunge happened
anybody who tucks their [__] shirt in
and is Young is up to no good
unless they go into church a wedding or
a funeral
somebody shows up and they got their
shirt tucked into their and they're
wearing like you can't tell if they're
slacks you don't really know what the
proper term is to just to the category
of their pants
if you're not sure what those are yeah
those people you that's the person
that's going to rat you out
you know
that's all I see when I come out I just
see a bunch of [__] rats
yeah
like just I don't know I mean maybe I
should lighten up right
I can't lighten up I'd have no podcast I
have to take everything seriously like I
uh went out after I landed here
um
I [__] went to go get something to
eat
uh you know took a walk hey take a
[__] walk should go get yourself
something to eat take a [__] walk huh
so I took a walk went down I got
something to eat I have never seen so
many young people with their [__]
goddamn button-down shirts tucked into
their pants it was like unsettling
I was actually going to ask the question
is weed legal out here I know I know it
isn't I know it isn't is being up after
nine o'clock legal
um
only if you're going to Epstein Island
maybe that's how you end up
you know at one of those [__] orgies
where you're just banging something you
don't even know what sex it is it's
wearing like a [__] donkey head right
you don't even know what you're doing
there
you're sort of in your body but not in
your body like I think all of those
years that tuck in your shirt into your
[__] pants at some point you got to
have you you got to have your your
Woodstock
right
like liberals like [__] outside
in like the grass and the mud
you know
like music festivals
let's be honest
incredible lineups of bands
okay in remote areas performing to a
bunch of sunstroke drugged up [__]
animals
you know you know that if it's too loud
it's too old man I can tell you this if
it's not in a venue I'm not [__]
going
I'm not gonna be out in the elements
you know watching people walking around
and trying to figure out if somebody's
on Molly or if they're if they have
scurvy
it's just I'm not doing that [__] all
right
and I stand I've stood by that I mean
I'll go to like uh an Amphitheater
you know what I mean I love the
amphitheater Vibe The Haves and the
have-nots
you know the chairs versus the people
they have out in the yard like [__]
rescue dogs
or or dogs that it will eventually be
rescue dogs you know
I think if you go to an Amphitheater
you know and you get lawn seats they
should actually tie you to something
like a like a [__]
livestock
when it gets hot they should just spray
you with the [__] fire hose you know
I think that's the way it's going to be
in the future
like I don't think that people
like like that's a big thing
in the corporate world
is creating like these different levels
it's like the Money Cash System it's
like India but with like just money you
know they have it on airplanes
you know airplanes is like the king of
it I mean they just cannot be enough
special groups and then they just keep
like breaking into other subsets of
special groups and
it just keeps pushing everybody back and
back and back and like oh my God
it's like a rocket going up into outer
space and you think you're in the
[__] capsule with the guy driving it
and all of a sudden you realize your
part broke off and you're falling back
down to Earth but I thought I was
special right
they always have to have
you know
they go to hotels there's always that
little extra
as you go up there's a little [__]
here and if you do this and you get
these points you know you spend this
amount of money then you get a little
[__] dinghy
all of that [__]
I don't know where I'm going with this
what the [__] am I talking about oh yeah
then you go to these these [__] music
festivals and they got the same thing
right
like you got the people like say that
that Woodstock 99.
thing
you know there was some sort of VIP
section where they weren't [__]
swimming in mud in their own [__]
getting trench mouth and all of that
[__] like those trench mouth can you
believe that ugh
you don't even want to look that up
um
but like
you [__]
I don't know
like I know people like my age that go
out to like Coachella
right and they like fly out there and
then they land and then they're in some
air-conditioned tent if they're watching
all these young people like dropping
like flies I don't know if this [__]
happens I just what I assume happens
and you're just sitting up there
looking down at them in this sort of I
don't know what it is
this illusion of safety
like at any point if any all the kids
down on the ground decide they've had
enough of you and your VIP little
air-conditioned tent they've taken that
[__] over
it's gonna be like one of those [__]
video games all the kids play you know
where you build your own City and then
all of a sudden other cities attack you
whatever whatever the hell that is
um
I haven't said that uh these are like my
last two stand up dates
for a couple of weeks
I'm doing here and I'm doing Philly and
I forgot my Dr J [__] basketball
sneakers son of a [__]
I bought a pair to specifically where in
Philly God damn it I do have Converse
All-Stars I got the blue ones though
[__]
oh well no I don't I brought the Nikes
oh well
ah Billy Billy Billy Billy Billy Billy
you [__] your brain's all over the
place
you working too hard
um what's this is the last time I'm
gonna work Philly well I'm not gonna
wear those [__] things until they
come back to Philly how about that
I'll do something
um I know what I'm not gonna do when I
go to Philadelphia is ask somebody where
to get a Philly cheesesteak I'm done
with that [__]
I'm done with it I think that that's
just like a uh they [__] with Taurus and
they just send you to the most obscure
walk-in closet in the middle of [__]
nowhere
and
I can't tell the difference
okay it's a big delicious greasy [__]
sandwich and I honestly
like you'd have to live there
you have to live there you got to grow
up there you got to have like child
sense memory as to why you like it but
if you just [__] come to town
some bald orange douche like me you're
not gonna be able to tell a difference
all right all I know is I'm not going to
the ones those two genos or um
or Piccadilly's whatever the [__] it's
called Genoa Pat I'm not going down
there
all right that always feels like there's
going to be a fight
any second
um
I know last time I went there somebody
actually told me to go to this place and
it was like it was too much
I mean by the time I got the sandwich to
the table the bread was soaking wet it
was so [__] greasy
which is also what makes it good I think
I don't know
um but anyway I'm looking forward to uh
doing two
incredible Sports towns DC
and Philly as far as
you know back
when I used to watch hockey back in the
80s and the Patrick's Patrick division
was just [__]
it was insane there was like seven teams
and you could drive to all of them like
in an hour it was nuts
except for Pittsburgh they would that
was like the road gig way the [__] out
there
see if I remember it was the Islanders
the Rangers the devils
the Flyers
the capitals
Pittsburgh
why did I think there was seven teams I
got to be missing one
Adam's division was the Canadians the
nordics
the Sabers the Bruins and the Whalers
and then it was [__] the Islanders
the Rangers The Devils the Flyers
Baltimore never had a team
capitals
the Cleveland Barons
now who the [__] were they then then the
Pittsburgh Penguins
why did I think there was seven
I don't know anyway they were just all
there they all [__] hated each other
and they all beat the [__] out of each
other it was [__] amazing and every
team had a couple of [__] tough guys
and then a couple of goal scorers
like let's see let me see if I can go
around and still remember
like who their guys were I can't [__] it
it was so goddamn long ago Ariel
obviously there was Mario Lemieux
he had Pat LaFontaine
Mike bossy
uh
uh who the Devils have
they had a bunch of conscious who they
had
Scott Stevens taking runs at everybody
they've fallen through in their shots he
would come by doing a drive-by give you
a nice [__] elbow to your [__]
head and your career
um Rod langway the big defenseman
clock Elise rest his soul
um then all the goaltenders pelly
Lindbergh rest his soul
uh after him was uh
oh my God Ron Hextall
Kate Peters went from Boston down to DC
Billy Smith
up with the Islanders
who the Devils have [__] Chico Resh I
can't remember
but it was insane
and what kills me is I only one time and
went I went to an Islanders Rangers game
at Nassau Coliseum in 1989
me and my buddies went down there one of
our friends was going to Hofstra
University
and dude it was it was [__] bananas
fights in the crowd
like guys in like suits and loafers like
you know their sport jackets off
throwing [__]
punches at each other
just [__] lunatics I remember being
in there and I didn't give a [__] about
either team I just gave a [__] about not
getting the [__] kicked out of me so I
just kept my mouth shut I just remember
kind of like being hammered and looking
up and seeing this fight and then
looking at my buddy we both just like ah
we are in the wrong quad
keep your [__] mouth shut
oh that was a classic
that weekend
remember the dude we rode down with
we were all getting hammered back at
Hofstra and for some reason he wanted to
go out he wanted to get some drugs or
something
and it was a cold night we're like all
right man be careful
he's like yeah don't worry about it
don't worry about it and he [__]
he left
went down to his car and he [__] came
back two seconds later and he's like
guys I wrecked my car like you wrecked
your car and we went out to the parking
lot
and it was this completely empty parking
except for this one little I can't
remember if I told this story here there
was one Island little island with one
little tree on it and he hit it dead
center
and blew out both his [__] front
tires
and we were just like dude what the why
did you [__]
we walked
and we walked around the car to the
front of it and the whole front
windshield was all frosted over except
for this little area where he had taken
two of his fingers
he just you know
you know like those Devo sunglasses he
basically did that to look at him so
obviously he didn't see it so he had to
call a tow truck that's right the tow
truck ended up showing up at like four
in the morning and there was this guy
and he had his wife and his little kid
in the car
and he got out
I thought he said tell me you didn't
[__] see this
that's what this guy said when I drove
my truck into a ditch one time
he goes tell me he didn't [__] see
this it's like well obviously I didn't
you [__] [__]
it was raining out
tell me you didn't [__] see this
who's was you know the the his he had
such a douchey [__] attitude it's
like to you did you you know what you
need you should go apply to work in a
music store
when I was growing up the biggest [__]
in the [__] world
were the ones that worked in music
stores
I hated those [__] it always made you
feel like an idiot
remember going in there I just started
playing drums and I got into Stuart
Copeland
I didn't know the name of the symbol
that he has you gotta you got to get one
of those little symbols you know small
ones you know kind of like this big the
guy like in front of everybody was like
you mean a splash
it's like yeah
what are you [__] 32 you're obviously
not gonna make it you [__] band
didn't make it too when you were 32 when
I when I was a kid 32 was it was [__]
over
people died of lung cancer at 32 but you
know when I was growing up you were
[__] old
like two gray hairs in your mustache
you [__] left over from the 70s
mustache you [__] [__] I still
remember that guy's face
um
should have taken a symbol and just
frisbied it at his head
it's the kind of [__] you could have
done back then and all you did was get
thrown out of the store if there wasn't
video and then a lawsuit
um
but then I wouldn't got the symbol you
know what's funny is I never bought this
symbol
because then I'd have to buy the stand
and do all of that [__] and it'd be too
much Goddamn money but I do remember
like
um
the cuntiness
in some of these music stores unless she
went there and you started taking
lessons you were spending some money
once you got to know him it kind of like
eased up but they were just like uh
man let's talk about [__] shall we
let's have the [__] of this show talk
about [__] I remember uh
you know I was trying to get and read a
bunch of books believe it or not I go
through Perry's where I'll read a bunch
of books and I'll read like heavy [__]
all the way to like stupid [__]
um
and I had read
one of the things I read was the Anthony
Kiedis
autobiography Scar Tissue right
so I that was in the stack
of books that I brought to this
bookstore used bookstores trying to get
rid of them and the guy was looking
through my books and at one point he got
to that one and he goes
because you actually bought this
and
I I didn't say anything but I just want
to be like
yeah I did
you know
if I bought the book about your life it
would be like three pages long
I did okay in school I moved to LA I
worked in a bookstore and then I was a
douche
you know or I could read Anthony Kiedis
talking about not wearing a shirt
from like the age of [__] two to like
42 banging everything that [__] moved
I could read that
I mean why wouldn't I read that
it's [__] up why didn't I think to
say that then I was just there's people
in line I just was just like
all right he's kind of got me you know I
read a [__] Rockstar's Auto Body I
read them all
I read slashes I read Stephen Adler's I
read everybody's in Guns and Roses
I read David Lee roths
I think those they're gonna those are
gonna be classic someday
you know [__] Beethoven wrote an
autobiography you wouldn't [__] read
that
talking about [__] taking off his
powdered wagon going down on some
[__]
harlot
worried that he's gonna get killed by
Jack the Ripper
do you know why they called him that
you know why he called him that he had
gas
he had really bad gas he used to fart a
lot when he was killing people
and people too afraid to go I'm sorry
Jack the
the never found him either
you know what I bet about Jack the
Ripper I bet he tucked his shirt into
his pants
he's one of those guys
by the way I cannot believe
how popular the Queen of England was
man that's like ridiculous
when was the last time she did anything
like was on TV
doing something
it's like she hasn't put an album out
forever
she's like the Tony Bennett a [__] uh
what do you call those people Royal
people
what do you call those people kings and
queens and dukes and duchesses and
princes and princes
royalty right
he's a royalty now he's a royal
I don't know
I wonder what that's like
you finally figured out like wait a
minute
I live in a castle
so this is where I'm gonna live in a
[__] castle and I have to have
security
all right it was cool you know
obviously nice place to live
but everybody already knows who I am
it's got to be a [__]
a weird thing you know
when like
parents decide that you're going to be
famous
but you ever see like these [__]
celebrities they just sit there and they
like they like they brand their kids
or they politicize them that's my
favorite thing you'll see some
three-year-old kid walking around with a
shirt that says the future is feminine
it's
[Music]
like what are you doing
what do you do with your kid you sit
down and watch Fox News or CNN is that
what the [__] you do with your kid
you could see those [__] lunatics
doing [__] like that too you know
just [__] their kids up
there's got to be a way to say that
without like swearing at somebody
like how do you say to somebody like you
know you realize you're [__] your kid
up right now you do realize that right
um
anyway uh
actually this Dad I know
um
I got to know through being in this
business he made a movie called teenage
emotions
I saw it it's really cool he just used
an iPhone
and he basically
filmed all these students talking
and through their conversations and
Steve would just give him subjects he'd
found a story line and put together this
really cool movie It's called teenage
emotions and it's coming out on is it
mubi
m-u-b-i on Thursday could chuck you
should check it out people are actually
really digging it who have watched it uh
um what am I doing here I'm gonna do a
little bit of advertising here
all right and you can believe in this
advertising because my shirt is not
tucked into my pants
um hey by the way you guys write in I
want to see someone that tells
when you know somebody's a douche
like when I was in my teenage years that
somebody had their collar popped
you knew that they were going to be a
douche
you know or
or you were just jealous because you
knew that they were going to end up
dating the chick that you liked
it's always you know it's always a
little bit you too you know
I don't mean the band
all right zip recruiter everybody
balancing
oh yeah when nobody wants to work
everybody wants to stay home I love how
everybody got to stay home and live like
a comedian and then all of a sudden all
right
you know the quarantine's over come on
back to work and I was like Hey [__]
go back to work
[__] that place all right zip recruit
everybody hiring is challenging
especially right now when you have so
much on your plate
uh luckily there's one place you can go
where hiring is simple fast and smart a
place where growing businesses connect
to qualified candidates that place is
zip
.com
doesn't work for you zip
up
recruiter uses its powerful technology
to find and match the right candidate up
with your job okay you don't have time
to sift through a bunch of [__]
losers you want winners you want number
one draft choices all right you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply another good thing is what does
their face look like do I want to look
at that face that face you know
he wants someone coming in to bring in
the sunshine
not partly cloudy three days of the week
zip recruiter is so effective that four
to five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day no wonder zip
is the number one rated hiring site
based on G2
satisfaction ratings as of January 1st
2022 and right now to try zip
uh for free my listeners can go to
ziprecruiter.com ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh look who it is everybody it's Helix
helix
h-e-l-i-x you know nothing is better
than a good night's sleep Helix sleep is
a premium mattress brand that provides
tailored mattresses based on your unique
sleep preferences the Helix lineup
includes 14 unique mattresses including
a collection of luxury models a mattress
for Big and Tall sleepers and even a
mattress made just for kids so how will
you know which Helix mattress works best
for your body take the Helix sleep quiz
and find your perfect mattress in under
two minutes and your personalized
mattress is shipped straight to your
door free of charge Helix knows there's
no better way to test out a new mattress
than finding somebody you dig putting
them on and [__] bang it no uh
mattress then by sleeping on it in your
own home that's why they offer 100 night
risk-free trial plus Helix mattresses
are an American made they're American
made and come with a 10 to 15 year
warranty depending on the model and
remember you get to try it out for 100
nights risk free if you don't love it
I know you will but if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for you gross and
give you a full refund
reach you to my Hazmat pocket
and get your refund I don't want to take
my word for it well Helix has been
awarded the number one mattress pick by
GQ and Wired Magazine who knew cokeheads
had a magazine it's even recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors for Sleep of sleep machine as a
go-to solution for improving your sleep
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to Helix sleep.com with
Helix better sleep starts now
all right lastly but not leastly
look who it is everybody it's old
stamps.com you know if you're a small
business owner you know how important it
is to be ready for the insane holiday
season if you haven't started preparing
for the chaos of holiday oh my God we're
gonna start shopping here
holiday mailing and shipping you're
already falling behind I like this
causing stress making me feel like I'm
I'm I'm behind luckily stamps.com has
made everything you need
oh has everything you need to make your
life a whole lot easier you've heard me
talk about stamps.com they've been
sponsoring for this wonderful show for
over nine years and if you haven't tried
it yet what are you waiting for
stamps.com is one of your top shops uh
your One-Stop shop sorry for all your
shipping and mailing needs a stress-free
solution for every small business
use stamps.com to print postage where uh
whenever you wherever you do business
all you need is a computer and a printer
and if you need a package
pickup you can easily schedule it
through your stamps.com dashboard get
ahead of the holiday chaos this year get
started with stamps.com today oh yeah
get out shop and then ship it out and
then you can sit around getting hammered
as everybody else runs out to Amazon
nobody really runs out to the mall
anymore do they sign up with promo code
bird for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code Burr
b-u-r-r all right and with that
let's keep talking here let's keep
yapping like the two cute old ladies on
my flight
good Lord there was these two adorable
old ladies in front of me and about with
a third of the flight left
they started talking to each other you
know they're talking over a jet and
they're all so old so they can't hear
each other just like what
it was hilarious and also really
annoying so I put on my my [__]
headphones
I had to put I had to go with AC DC to
try and drown him out
um but anyway
I had a really good day and I'm thankful
for it and I'm also thankful for the
fact that I had a bunch of wonderful
people helping me work on this movie and
we're almost done with it we uh
we shot
a couple of scenes one added scene and
we re-shot another scene and on Monday
and
I just had such a [__] great time
and as much as I've been bitching about
all this work I know I'm going to do
this again because it's fun and we all
had a great time and uh I think you guys
are gonna like this movie when we're
done with it I'm excited it's getting
close
it's getting close and uh like I've been
saying when this movie comes out I need
to I'm calling in a favor to all the use
uh to go out wherever you
wherever you're going to be able to see
it
um I would appreciate it if you could
support it if you can't I get it people
are busy but I'd appreciate it all right
well that is the podcast everybody
um who do you like who do you like the
judges are playing uh what the [__] are
they playing tomorrow night
I can't even remember
I'm gonna be doing a show
I'm gonna have my wife tape the game
um
I'll try I'll try to watch it you know
I'm on the road so I come home I gotta
play with my kids
uh
which is awesome you know my son broke
his garbage truck got this great gift a
big garbage truck he loves the thing and
you know the cab comes forward like
you're going to work on the engine and
he [__]
pulled it too hard he's a little so I
found a hobby store that fixed it and I
gave it back to him I was so excited
because I used to get sad when my toys
were broken
and um
I didn't want him to feel that right so
I got it fixed and he had it for about
eight hours before he did it again
so I was like all right I gotta wait
till it gets like a little bit older but
um I went by the uh Harley-Davidson
store I always go in there and I want to
look at a road kink I always just go and
look at that [__] but they had these
little toy motorcycles and I got my son
one and he freaked out
I came and I had it behind my back in
the box I was like hey buddy look it and
he goes oh he's like most psycho Mo
psycho that is motorcycle no it's yours
he's like motorcycle open open I'm like
yeah and he's had that thing in his hand
for like the last two days and now and
even when he pushes around his Tonka
trucks he puts it in the back of the
truck and pushes it around he's such a
little badass
um he likes trucks and motorcycles it's
just awesome
um
and I've been hanging out with my
daughter I've been having a good time
now that now hopefully that my
schedule's slowing down a little bit so
that's all good uh that's it college
football pro football Yankees have
righted the ship I think I think they're
gonna [__] still hang on and win the
division we'll see baseball playoffs are
coming up Aaron judge looks like he's
gonna break the record I hope more
people care about it and that's about it
that's it everybody all right uh enjoy
the weekend you [__] and uh we got a
little bit of music here
or maybe some bad MGM stuff for all I
know I have no idea and then we'll have
a bonus episode bonus half hour after
this after the music of uh Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast from an episode I
recorded
I don't know when I don't know how he
figures it out all right that's it I'll
see you
[Music]
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday
sorry that was obnoxious for Monday
September uh 15 2014 how's it going how
are you what's up
um my [__] house is hot as [__]
goddamn AC I don't know what's going on
with it I really got to stop doing this
I gotta stop trashing my house because
someday you know maybe I'll sell it
you know and no matter how many photos I
put up that makes it look like it's all
shiny and new come aboard
we want to sell it to you it's my [__]
home
they added the bottom floor in the 50s
my
[__] home
are you into dry rot wood because that's
what I have behind all the plaster you
see sorry
now we're actually turning the [__]
corner
downstairs they've roughed it up and
they are ready to now put the final
touches
on a downstairs that should have been
built like this to begin with
you know what my downstairs basically is
because this originally was a one floor
house it's like an expansive expansion
franchise
my downstairs when I bought this house
unbeknownst to me was the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers in 1977. okay and Sam not Sam
Huff Gary Huff
Gary
Huffman I think that's the name of the
original Tampa Bay Buccaneers
quarterback
um that um of that team that went Owen
14. he designed the downstairs
all right he designed the [__]
downstairs so anyways everything has
been corrected everything has been
aligned everything is square everything
is true learning all these construction
words
all right
that and uh hey I don't know if you saw
the last invoice but we're still waiting
for payment that's another big
construction term
I think those [__] they somehow
they put a flat on one of them on my uh
my bicycle it's not my bicycle it's the
one I bought for Nia and she never used
it
you know so I I actually write it now I
write it through the Canyons no every
once in a while I'll take it out for a
spin and uh I should have known because
the front tire needed a little bit of
air but the back one was just done
and I pumped them back up and everything
was good I listened I didn't hear any
sound so I thought it was [__] fine
and then I went down there and the
things you know just one of the added
costs and I gotta tell you if I was a
[__] not saying I'm not but if I was
like a a motivated
if I was trying to make All-American
in the [__] category I would actually
take the the whatever it's going to cost
me to have somebody put a new [__]
inner tube in it if it was the front
tire I'd do it myself but it's the back
tire and uh you know old freckles
doesn't have time for that [__] I could
go on YouTube sure I could do it
how to change back tire
and move all of that [__] out of the way
and I could get all [__] greasy and
then have to go down to Home Depot and
buy that [__] that that that Salve
that cuts through the grease
and I'd be down there for nine hours you
know and afterwards yeah I'd feel like a
man
you know
or I could just drop it off and have
somebody [__] do it
and uh
I could sit here and eat a pizza
no not a pizza not a pizza I gotta have
a salad I gotta turn this [__] around
um a couple weeks ago I don't know what
happened like two and a half weeks ago I
had whatever the meal was that sent me
back down the road eating bad I've been
eating bad for two weeks and the other
day I walked by the mirror and I knew
I'd put on a few and I just I just was
so [__] disgusted with myself you
know and [__] all you [__] out there
that say that fat shaming doesn't work
you know
it doesn't work it's it's what it really
is is no you're fat and you don't want
to hear it that's what it is whenever I
say [__] about fat people it's not a
negative way
all right I'm trying to motivate you
it's how I motivate myself I walk by the
mirror and I look at myself and I go oh
you [__] piece of [__] really all
that [__] work we did
all those months of work
all those pull-ups all those push-ups
all those [__] hikes and what did you
do
what did you do you gave it all away
that's what kills me about when you're
at my age is I can lit I can negate
three months of being at the gym in four
meals not four meals but like in a week
in a week of just being an [__]
everything that I gained I can just
[__] lose it's the it's the absolute
worst so then if you don't know how to
diet what you do is then you start
lifting weights and that type of [__]
and you keep eating bad and all you're
doing is you're putting these pecs and
biceps on top of the big belly right
roll out the barrel we'll have a barrel
of fun right and you just become that
guy
that guy who just keeps lifting weights
and keeps eating [__] food and all
you're trying to do is keep your man
pecks just a little bit out in front of
your [__] stomach and then what do
you do you start pushing down the
[__] pants
your belt lines [__] digging into
your pubes so dude I'm still a [__]
32 inch waist same G same change size I
had an High School
and you just keep pushing it down and
pushing to the point it looks like
somebody yanked your belt and all the
fat went boing up to yeah literally
bling just like that it was a bad sound
effect but you know what I'm saying all
the way up into your gut and then it ran
into your [__] man pecs that held it
down and it's just [__] sitting there
caught between a rock and a hot place
that'd be a pecks in your dick there
sorry
um
so I'm trying to avoid that that's the
hardest [__] thing is to lose weight
and not lose muscle you know and [__]
all you guys who are going to come at me
with your GNC chemicals
all right and talking about protein the
size of your hand I've heard all of it
I've heard all of it all right but what
are you supposed to do when that [__]
redneck comes on TV and says I got big
news they've now put bacon in in [__]
cheese in the crust whatever the [__] he
said I actually retweeted the quote why
don't I look it up
this is how [__] up it is right and
this guy's just sitting there hey I got
big news I got big news people
you know people who maybe are in between
jobs and can't afford quality food
and rather than encouraging to go out
and get an apple or a banana you know
what I'm gonna say I'm gonna how much
where the [__] is the thing
gonna find my tweet here I gotta find my
[__] Twitter
ah Jesus what the [__] I apologize
you know
I I have big news bacon and cheese have
been stuffed into a crust that's what
this guy says is he sits in his [__] do
you think that [__] [__] is eating
maybe he's eating a little bit of it he
is from the south and I'll tell you he
don't know no better
I'll tell you what the only thing better
than that greasy Italian food is if you
shove a little bacon and grease here in
the crust
there you go do you like that joke I
attacked two [__] people
actually I really was just making fun of
Southerners
right
anyways and he's just sitting there
collecting the money basically sitting
in the guard Tower as all of us [__]
March in to [__] eat that poison how
do you do that in good conscience how
can you sit there as a country singer
all right all about your family values
and supporting the troops and denying
global warming how can you sit there
cross your [__] Wrangler jeans with
your [__] kicking boots on and say to
America I have big news
bacon and cheese have been stuffed into
a crust
you [__]
he always stuffed into a duffel bag a
bunch of [__] cash for you to go out
and buy smokes go Bandit right and go
get a replica of the [__] Dukes of
Hazzard car while everybody else goes in
and they add to their [__] man tits
how dare you
you're already quit on your [__]
music career the second you got in that
Lazy Boy where you spin around and face
the crowd then you come back around and
tell somebody from a from a warehouse
that they got a shot whatever [__]
whatever that show is
I don't you know what's funny is back in
the day whenever you did shows like that
you never made it now people actually
make it
you know do you remember a long time ago
on uh MTV they had Making the Band
nobody ever made it
nobody ever [__] made it that's why I
never went on Last Comic Standing
I never went on that because that's all
I thought about was MTV Making the Band
everybody who went on making the band
never made it
I was thinking you know Nirvana wasn't
on making the band
they didn't do a show like that did did
you know did Cinderella go on making the
band I don't think they did
you know went on the band or who went on
that [__] the real world did I still
do that show
we played seven [__] people in the
house and we're gonna show you what
happens I love how they they like that's
a
a point of Pride with MTV this is where
it all started
Oh you mean that [__] TV where you take
regular people and exploit them and have
them scream at each other oh Bill get
off you [__] eye horse you watch it
just like the rest of us all right
you're right you're right I do and then
have I told you I started watching that
[__] arm wrestling show
Battle of arms or whatever it is that's
the funniest [__] I've ever seen in my
least guys are [__] out of their
minds
getting each other's faces right before
the arm wrestle what are you God
screaming at each other [__] slamming
the table around
I love that show
these [__] guys would rip your
goddamn arm off
um I don't know what that deal is some
of them are actually like they can't
help being like that and then there's
other ones that are [__] terrified I
don't know what it is they had a bad
father and now they're going to try to
become like as close as they can to a
Goddamn superhero so they they got us
every pull-up they gotta scream
ah
right
shouting the fear out of them whatever
good for them you know God bless them in
other words I don't have anything else
to say about that topic so whenever I
don't I just yeah you know what God
bless them
God bless those sons of [__] my arms
all swollen
I didn't know that that happened
that when you arm wrestle to that point
that one of your arms just blew up like
a balloon I remember back in the day
when you were out in the backyard and a
mosquito got on you and if you flexed
your muscle really quick they couldn't
release and you'd blow them up with your
own blood do you remember doing that
[__]
well I do I remember because I came up
before the internet why isn't my [__]
AC cooling off this room
can you hear it can you hear it humming
in the background oh it's trying
that AC is trying just like I'm trying
right now I'm trying to entertain you
[__] for another goddamn hour
on another [__] Monday right
there it is people
congratulations you lived another week
starting all over again
what are you doing right now how are you
sitting in your [__] car you in
traffic
you're behind that douchebag who for
some reason leaves two and a half car
lengths between him and the other car
on a flat surface on a dry Road for
whatever reason he's doing that and yet
another person is cut into your lane
it's your lane
and you're sitting there gripping the
steering wheel going you know what
in a perfect [__] world
perfect [__] world I would punch
through his side window like The
Terminator
I would pull him out by his [__]
throat lift him high into the air
choke The Life just almost to an inch of
his life leave him by the side of the
road and then get in his car
am I the only one thinks [__] like that
I don't think I am I think it's a very
normal thought
um
anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast
and uh
um it's football Sunday right now it's
actually 1 18. I just watched the New
England Patriots
somehow after that first horrific drive
they finished off the uh Minnesota
Vikings I got to tell you man I love
seeing the Vikings playing outside again
reminding me of way back in the day was
Fran Tarkington Jim Marshall
Paul Krause Chuck Foreman
remember that Allen page
Carl Eller
well you know all these guys as I'm
saying that I'm picturing football cards
do Voit or some [__] who's that [__]
Ron Yari maybe he was in the 80s
when they had Tony
Kramer Tommy Tommy Kramer
um
he played indoors they they I when I
started watching football the Vikings
still still played outside I think for
like one or two seasons it was the late
70s I I think it was just the last
season or I might have been
I was just watching those NFL films all
the time so I think I remembered it I
have no idea
oh [__]
the Seahawks and charges are playing
hang on I gotta hit pause I gotta I
gotta record this game hold on hold on
hold on hold on
okay I'm back I'm back sorry I had to
make sure I recorded that game I want to
watch that game uh
you know that's one of those games I
gotta tell you you know it could go
either way the Seattle Seahawks have
looked very impressive early this year
in the National Football League season
of 2014.
but you got to remember this is a
division rivalry even though they're not
in the same division they've played each
other for years they know what each
other does
it's really going to come down to who's
going to strap it on what did they mean
by that strap it on
you gotta strap it on look that other
guy in the eye
and you got to play some Smash Mouth
football
that's what they need to do
the San Diego charges for years have
been trying to get over the hump they
they have they've created a culture
where they they get to the big game but
they just cannot seem to get to the big
dance
sorry
um you know what's funny is I make fun
of it and the only way I know everything
that they say is because I watch it all
the time and I can't stop [__]
watching it
I can't stop [__] watching it you
know
um anyways
plowing ahead here
uh
uh let's get back to the [__] what
did I want to talk about this week let's
just get out of football because I know
there's a lot of people that don't like
football not that I give a [__] but I
you know I don't wanna I don't wanna
bore you
100 so uh what are you doing this week
you know what I'm doing uh coming up on
uh
coming up on oh wait wait wait
scatterbrain scatterbrain hit the brakes
um I want to let you guys know on
Twitter I announced that my uh my
long-awaited Carnegie Hall recording I
did a show there on November 11 2011 and
the album is finally coming out I did it
on uh Third Man Records Jack White's
label in Nashville Tennessee and this
was the thing
um
you know I was doing a show at Carnegie
Hall and I was getting ready to do a
special
videoing shooting whatever a special at
Carnegie Hall would have cost me nine
million dollars why because their
Carnegie Hall and they know everybody
wants to record there so they charge it
10 million times what the [__] they
should be charging so it's Carnegie Hall
I don't know if I'm ever going to be
back it's like I gotta record this I got
a document that I'm gonna be there right
so I did
they charged me ten fifteen thousand
times what the [__] they should have
charged but I didn't give a [__] because
it was Carnegie Hall flow and behold
they were right so
uh three months later I recorded uh you
people are all the same
and then about like a year later I
finally got the tapes that's how slow
things move
um I could have got access into the
White House quicker than I got the tapes
from my uh my show there and and it was
one of the deals with just the overlap
because it was like three four months
between that recording and my next
special that it was basically I don't
know 80 85 75 percent the same [__] you
know I tell it differently every night
but it's the same [__] so
I want to [__] put it out that I've
been there
I don't want to [__] people over by you
know acting actually acting like this
isn't this is new material it isn't it's
just this performance of that material
so uh I decided that I was putting it
out on vinyl only and uh that way it's
you know even though it's the same thing
it's like a different sort of
I don't know I think albums are cool and
I know everybody for some reason equates
them to hipsters which I guess is fair
but to be honest with you guys I'm 46
years old I grew up when you know I
remember when cassette tapes came out
um you know
all of my [__] when I first got it was
on vinyl I don't think it sounds better
I can't tell if it sounds better I have
no [__] idea what I do like is I like
I liked albums
at first I like the cassettes where it
was all small and that type of [__] oh
this is great I can take it in the car
and all that type of thing then after a
while I went back to the final no this
is much [__] cool you get all these
extra pictures
you know it was a [__] event I liked
it I liked it so whatever so some people
giving me [__] for doing it I don't give
a [__]
the fact that it's on vinyl
I just look at it as if you actually buy
this [__] thing you can't give me
[__] it's that it's the the pretty much
the same thing it's just
I've told you from day one okay so I
don't want to [__] hear it even
though I'm still gonna hear it and all
you guys with your dumb jokes you put
your next special out on beta man
snort snort laughing my ass off I don't
give a [__] um
it's really cool and uh so let me tell
you a little bit about the album if you
look at the cover of the album you'll
see old uh Billy redface standing on
stage grinning ear to ear but there's
not a soul in the place
um because we could not shoot during the
show those were the rules Union house
Carnegie Hall go [__] yourself for
Carnegie Hall
so I had to take the photo then
all right and uh my photographer was
allowed to be
I don't know
there was a little hole in the wall he
was able to stick the camera through and
take pictures it was [__] insane
was insane and uh the naval name of the
album is called uh live at Andrew's
house
and um
and then that was just another thing
where I wanted to say live at Carnegie
Hall but that was going to be like you
know it was just going to be another
thing but we have to get that approved
you know oh you got to approve that I
was I mean I
I was there I paid the money to rent out
the thing you know you saw the show you
didn't have problem we still have to
send it up
send it up the flagpole blah blah blah
and I just said [__] it [__] it I won't
I don't need to say that I'll just say
live at Andrew's house
there you go Andrew Carnegie all right
there you go so there you go there's a
little history there okay
so that's going to be available I think
on September 30th uh
um the pre-ordering is like oh Jesus
Bill why don't you go why don't you just
get the [__] information before you
start talking about it you dumb [__]
um let me see here let me see here where
is it my gravy
ladondo my gravy no he's not down
German cars are the best German cars go
to the best level
by the way I'm back into that
Mercedes-Benz uh
that Mercedes-Benz [__] station wagon
I just think that's the coolest thing
all right
um
is this it here okay pre-sale is on
September 16th which is tomorrow if
you're listening to it
uh
on Monday you know if you listen to at
the right time if you're not it's
probably already out that's the pre-sale
is 9 16 and it's on sale on 9 30. full
details full details excuse me hiccups
all right third manrecords.com
um I hope you guys like it I've already
given a couple copies of people and they
say it's awesome but they're also
friends of mine so
I imagine you [__] will be a little
more honest dude it [__] sucked
um all right back to the uh to the
podcast so this week
after the Ray Rice Scandal now you got
Adrian Peterson
and um
I gotta admit
I was absolutely shocked
by that [__] story
um I know that you know that's something
that has gone on for a long [__] time
parents beating their children like that
I just
for some reason I just didn't think you
know with all
this Dr Phil [__] all this
pop psychology [__] that's out there how
you could hit a kid
with a switch that's four years old to
the point that he's uh
bruised and bleeding is just [__]
Beyond
my uh comprehension that's just [__]
nuts
I think that that really [__] obviously
really [__] people up when you when you
when you do [__] like that um to that
level I'm not saying I didn't get hit as
a kid but two things one it wasn't a
switch it was a paddle
and two I [__] deserved it
I never felt
um that it was wrong the no what is it
what am I what's the word I'm searching
for I never felt that I didn't uh didn't
do something to deserve it
I hated it because it hurt but I never
felt that it was um
like it was uh I don't know like all I
did was this and then you did that the
only time I ever felt it was [__]
wrong was one time my brother said that
I kicked my other brother in the face
and it was [__] I kicked him in the
stomach
I used to do a bit about that and it was
that which was considered working it out
amongst yourselves and uh you know the
face was a No-No in my house was weird
you could punch in the side of the head
if you bruised within the hair
you know the parents wouldn't see it
then you'd be all right but if you hit
in the face then you know then you had a
big problem
and um
yeah my mother was brushing her hair at
the time she turned around she went to
whack me over the head with a brush and
I ducked and she caught me right between
the shoulder blades
and the brush was like this hard plastic
and it kind of exploded
and um
then my mother picked up the brush part
the rubber part with the thing sticking
out and for
and I think another 10 years I she
brushed her hair just holding on to that
rather than the whole with the handle
and all that like that's how
um
I don't know my parents their parents
grew up in the depression so they just
had that instilled in them that you you
know if the brush breaks into a million
pieces you still Salvage it it still
works you just hold it this way you know
which way you know maybe that's the
smartest thing to do I have no idea but
anyways taking it to that level so I
actually was reading about that and then
that reminded me of the story now this
comes with the warning because you
probably shouldn't watch this video but
it reminded me of a which I thought was
like seven eight years ago turns out it
was 20 years ago remember that kid was
like Michael Faye or something like that
was that uh
there's a 19 year old kid he was over in
Singapore
and he was accused of uh vandalizing
some property or some [__] and the
punishment what part of the punishment
was he was going to get caned
and you know nobody over here had heard
of it for the most part unless she
traveled
and it was basically they hit you with
this [__] stick
and
um
you know they hitch hit you hard enough
that after a couple of hits like
basically like they said pieces of Flesh
are coming off your [__]
ass in the back of your legs and stuff
and everybody thought it was [__]
horrific he was supposed to get six hits
and
we were allowed to well we made enough
of a stink that they went down to four
hits
and so I looked that up and then there
was a a link to a video that showed
somebody getting caned and I gotta tell
you don't watch it
don't watch it I watched it it's like a
four and a half minute video dude and
I'm telling you
because what happened with that Michael
Faye kid is like the day after something
he was sitting down so everybody's like
oh that wasn't that bad
that kid is a tough kid he's not like a
40 year old man but I gotta tell you
something I watched this video
dude it's just you go out there right
naked as a jay bird whatever the [__]
that means and then they put you in this
thing
that's almost like uh it's like what
they I don't know it's you're basically
I don't know like if you had like a
two-wheeled dolly you remember how they
wheeled Hannibal Lecter out marriage
they wheeled him out except he was
facing the other way
all right but there's no wheels on this
thing and you walk and you stand on that
thing then you hang on to these two
[__] handles and two people on either
side hold on to your arms
and then they put this thing over you
where there's basically I guess it's to
protect your lower back and the back of
your legs
you know so they don't hit that part and
then just your ass is poking through
this [__] hole
it's like a glory hole except it's your
ass
um
and then this [__] dude
Singaporean dude Filipino dude whatever
you call them
he lines up ready to hit you and he
waits for some [__] guy off camera to
be like right and this [__] guy is
just like in that classic Asian like
martial arts I can't even describe it
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon like I am
I'm gonna [__]
I'm gonna show the West
what [__] torque is really capable of
I can't even do it it looked like he was
getting ready to do some dance he was
[__] I'm literally trying I'm acting it
out right I'm standing up right
basically you stand up he's turned
sideways like he's gonna hit a [__]
golf ball then he [__] bends his back
leg so his right leg his other his front
leg is straight and his [__] arm is
all the way up like this guy and he's
ready to just [__] and he just and the
guy goes hey and this guy just goes
[__] whoops
and a dude right by the second one and
then they [__] wait like 30 seconds
it's just sitting there and this [__]
guy is standing there
he's supposed to hold the the [__]
almost said switch the cane a different
way and he's standing there and then
some guy mumbles some [__] right and
then the [__] guy goes back into that
that
pre-stance
he looks like a [__] Marvel comic
like action hero right and then the guy
goes hey and the [__] guy goes wow
hits him again the guy goes like like by
the second one
you sound like a puppy getting kicked
right and I swear to God the camera
because I think they were trying to show
how abusive it is then zoomed in on this
dude's ass and he's got like [__] two
lines now I think by the second hit it
was getting raw and both of his butt
cheeks were like [__] quivering like
anticipation dude this was like a four
and a half [__] I lost count
I think they hit him like five [__]
times
but uh literally by the fourth time the
guy started to like crumple dude it was
[__] brutal
I don't even know why I'm telling I'm
just saying this is like classic
internet thing like I went on NFL
nfl.com and then next thing you know I'm
watching somebody get caned in Singapore
and that's what's great about the
internet and it just it breaks down
people close
I don't know what to tell you I don't
know what the point of all of that was
um
listen I told you what happened you can
watch it if you want to watch it I'm not
putting the link up because I never I
never watched [__] like that and I don't
know why I did
it's just like one of those things
because it didn't seem like it was going
to be that bad and you start going dude
can I take that
could I sit there and for and for the
for America not cry out
you know
you just got to get the first one in to
understand the level
it's this I would think that that would
be Nah if you got the first one then
then that's psychologically like [__] I
got like three of this [__] I'm gonna
tell you what the US government did for
that Michael Faye dude that they they
got rid of the last two
I mean Jesus [__] crying like the way
I've described it now there's no way
you're not going to watch it but I'm not
putting the [__] link up but Jesus
there's no how many think it could take
do you know the other kid that got
arrested with him I'm literally talking
about a [__] news story from 20 years
ago the other kid was lined up for 12 of
those hits and they knocked his down to
10. dude you [__] unconscious by
eight
there's just no way you're either
unconscious or you can't even feel your
ass anymore your ass
[__] voice cracking
um
yeah dude that's that's uh that's
surprising that that is uh I know is it
really surprising
with all the [__] that's going on
that's why I don't watch the [__]
news I don't I have no idea anything
that's really going on I have to get
better at it especially now that I'm
building an hour
um
I gotta start watching it but like I've
never been one of those people that
could watch like
execution videos and [__] all like
people who sit down and they watch those
guys getting beheaded over there and
that's that does something to you to sit
down and watch that
[Music]
um
I don't know you know what's funny right
now is I every you know reason why I
wish I didn't watch that video I'm gonna
tell you what's gonna happen if you
watch that [__] video that dude's
quivering ass is gonna be burned into
your [__] brain for like three days
because now that's just what I'm
thinking right I'm trying to go on to
the next subject do you understand this
and there's a man's quivering ass
[Music]
it's in my no disrespect to that guy
this guy took it like a [__] Champ
Jesus [__] Christ
you know what's for the if you saw the
way this guy was swinging this cane like
they go to school for it
maximum [__]
velocity torque whatever the [__] you're
gonna call it all of that [__]
it's like they must have measured it out
Jesus Christ you know you always hear
about Singapore too how [__] clean
I'm actually afraid to go over there
because that's one of those things like
if you spit gum out on the street
you know that's considered that's a
crime
the next thing you know you [__] bare
ass
sitting there with a quiver and asses
some guy's going hey
[__] that
[__] that not saying they're bad people
I'm just saying I I can't live up to
those standards I'm gonna do something
stub my toe and then curse in public
hey
I'm gonna that's what I would do I'd be
[__] screaming like a [__]
my pasty quivering ass isn't that what
you wanted to think about on a Monday
morning sorry
how's your Danish
um anyway
s
um
Jesus Christ I bet that that guy has
[__] that guy who got caned or
anybody who gets caned anytime somebody
old bends over to tie their shoes and
they get a pain in their back and they
go they like their ass starts just
[__] tenses up like they're gonna get
[__] hit
um we got it Bill we got it they hit
people with wood in Singapore there you
go you learned something
um all right let's get on uh let's get
on to something else here
um as always people if you want to
donate to the podcast the best way to do
it is to not have to give me any money
simple next time you're gonna buy
something on amazon.com just go to
billbird.com First click on the podcast
page then click on the Amazon link it'll
take you right to Amazon it doesn't cost
you any extra money but if you come from
my website they kick me a few bucks
there you go
yeah kick me a few bucks and then I
throw it into the basement
sorry
um
anyways continuing on um
I don't know if I mentioned this to you
um
you know when we
aren't at the house you know I can't
bring my awesome dog with me everywhere
I go so uh but I also didn't want to
stick her in a little [__] kennel
thing
but she gets freaked out if she's in the
house by herself because somebody left
her by a river so she does not like to
be alone
but uh the dog trainers say but if you
put them in like a small sort of
container they don't feel overwhelmed by
the space they just curl up and go to
sleep well that's not my dog my dog then
tries to [__] break out of it and it
does and then it's upstairs and it's
sitting there wagging its tail and you
know it chipped a tooth or it's got a
cut on his face and it [__] kills me
so um what I did was I had this guy
I met this guy and he made these giant
what looked like a [__] Lions cage
and it was all this [__] rebar so it
was this bigger place where she could
ever bet in a place for a food you know
it's like a studio apartment as opposed
to a little case so I [__] put it
used to put her in that
and it was all good she tried to get out
of it a little bit then she realized
that I that I couldn't at least I
thought that that was the case
and um
she [__] broke up
you [__] she found the weakest bar
because it wasn't attached on both sides
it was only attached
just the way it was attached I don't
know how it figured it out but it just
used all of its body weight and it made
both welds fail and then it took that
bar and buried it under its bed and then
squeezed itself at some point I just do
a bit on this thing too another one at
some point it did a pull up or it had to
do a pull-up and then a dip and got out
the top of the [__] cage
so it then took this cage that I spent
700 bucks on and just rendered the whole
[__] thing useless
and I just take her everywhere I go
and uh because eventually I was gonna
have that thing welded back on
and I don't know what happened I just
started looking up for welders I stuck
looking at welding I got into this [__]
I think it's a school a cool uh skill to
learn
so I'm gonna take a six hour do it
yourself [__] welding thing
and I'm gonna [__] weld that thing
back on myself I'm gonna give it a shot
and I know what all you guys are
thinking dude you're gonna burn your
[__] [__] house down there's no
[__] way as dumb as I am okay give me
a little credit there's no [__] way I
would weld anything near my house
okay I'll pay the guys down at the shop
to let me do it at their shop under
their supervision okay before you call
me a [__] and before you predict all
this [__] disaster I'm not saying I'm
not gonna burn something down it just
won't be mine
all right that's the deal
I think learning how to I'm learning to
wear failed I think learning how to weld
is a really [__] cool ass skill it
really is and uh I'll show you a link to
uh the best video
of it that I found unless I got rid of
it please tell me I didn't get rid of it
this guy was awesome
he was totally clear he had a [__]
mustache
oh Jesus Christ you [__] Bill
you're the worst
you're just the [__] worst I will
find it
I will find it and I'll I'll give you
the [__] link and if I don't just
remind me how's that does that work for
you well I don't give a [__] oh my God
37 minutes and I haven't even holy [__]
we haven't done any advertising yet
um all right yeah I think it's time for
questions you know what
Jay lawhead is actually here he's over
my house right now I think he's watching
Seattle [__] charges we're going to
bring him in here to the podcast after
these not a message I just gave you a
message so I'm gonna bring him in here
through the wonderful world of hitting
pause
all right we're back to the wonderful
world the magic of hitting the pause
button uh we're now here with uh Rose
Bowl tailgate Legend and uh Gourmet Chef
of the outdoor backyard festivities of
the Rose Bowl the granddaddy of them all
Jason lawhead everybody
from the law heads court and some paint
um how's it how's it looking in there
it's good man uh San Diego's uh they got
their number Seattle actually got a
touchdown on literally the worst call in
the history of the NFL because these
chairs are really squeaky by the way
sorry
but what was the call you know they
review every touchdown if you score a
touchdown they review it now they have a
new system in New York City where they
watch every single bit of film Percy
Harvin stepped out on like the 36. they
didn't even review it they didn't review
the score they put it on a board and
then they go to Mike Perry afterwards
they're like oh yeah he stepped out of
bounds they should have like you know
the automatic review so who's that [__]
San Diego yeah
San Diego do I know right because I know
I know Cleveland you know you guys go
obviously you've been through a bunch of
[__] but there's something like San
Diego is always right there but Seven
Pro Bowlers every year and then somehow
like there's always either a call or
they shoot themselves in the fireman one
year they had us beat they had us beat
in a playoff game they stopped us on
fourth down to get the ball to end the
game they took an unnecessary roughness
call gave us a first down and then we
were able to kick a field goal to some
[__] and I was just like why why
would you do that and then there was
like that three or four years ago when
they had that fumble Denver when they
reviewed it and they were like yeah it
was a fumble San Diego recovered but
we're giving it to Denver I used to do a
whole bid on it when I was living in San
Diego about North Turner at a press
conference how I would have reacted I
mean they literally the the ref went
yeah
San Diego recovered it but there was a
whistleblown so we're giving it back to
Denver two plays later Denver scores
kept San Diego out of the playoffs that
year no it's it's
a special I don't know they did
something down there that that they're
getting that level of karma I don't know
we went to that game a long time ago did
not have a good time did not did not
they came against the Titans and uh
we've talked about this I think in the
last podcast with the Jersey coming off
in the fight yeah that merryman Jersey
we gotta have a we gotta have the
weather starting to turn into that we
got to have a pre-season tailgate you
know to get us ready for the Rose Ball I
mean we got to have something you want
to go to a USC game by the way oh
because I haven't been as a prac that's
a good practice we'll go to UFC game but
can you tailgate down there
yeah you can actually there's uh it's
not as convenient I'll go to UCLA's
higher ranked really dude [__] BC
beat USC USC is going to be out of the
uh top 25. UCLA's 12th in the country so
we should go to the UCLA game I know but
you know it's like I mean the Super Bowl
one and two were played it's [__]
goddamn half hour ride down the street
and it's just like I I only went there
one time I saw them play uh USC play
uh Washington Huskies in like 96. it's
the last time I've been there yeah I
went and uh oh
seven we went there we had a two-year
contract with them and they just waxed
us
that's the year they won a national
college day we went there with Beanie
Wells but he didn't play first game well
Speedy Wells didn't play the first game
of the season and we got worked over and
uh it was the only loss we had all year
we went 12-1 that year it was the first
second game of the season at USC that's
the only time I've ever been to the
Coliseum all right well I gotta go I
gotta get you can Tailgators good
tailgates going on down at the Coliseum
they got a lot of room down there by
campus I just get spoiled yet UCLA I
went and saw Andrew Luck there go and
saw Andrew Luck there I saw Andrew luck
to you his senior year how did I not
remember that I went even took a little
video I went down and did a little uh
nice luck luck video like what do you
what's the luckiest thing ever happened
to you I gotta show that to you go to
lawhead's court uh you know YouTube page
and you can find that uh all right well
fresh off the uh the the highly
successful all-in tour the first leg of
it we're hoping to put together a second
leg of it uh we got the questions for
this week
um let's see what we got here it says uh
what's new Billy Bonanza I live in
Toronto and was able to see black and
white it got me thinking why don't you
have a TV show surely the Hollywood
system seems the sees the value in your
song and dance get off your lazy ass and
come into my living room for 20 10 weeks
out of the Year love you and love Nia I
mean how do you answer that he would
have been smart if he would have if he
would have wrote lazy ass like you say
lazy ass or ladies that say that would
have been a little bit of flavor he
could have yeah but you know there's no
R in there yeah that's true but ladies
don't have an R
no that's Jerry Lewis that's who I'm
doing I know you are but you know you
throw out different references of this
you stretch the words on different ones
well maybe you wrote it that way it was
my read all I know is look you saw the
movie black and white you know what I
love I love that I'm in a [__] movie
and that's not enough for you that
wasn't enough for you I gotta have a
[__] TV show too and then you what
you do is you'll [__] that my comedy
isn't as good because I'll be spending
all my [__] time doing that [__]
pretending to be a [__] police
officer or whatever the hell thing I
would have now listen I gotta tell you
something uh I do have some [__] and
works but uh you know sometimes a lot of
you know it's a blessing to not have a
TV show it's a blessing to in this
business go on other people's shows
because they deal with all the
responsibilities the writing the
conference calls all of that [__] is uh
when I have time to learn how to weld
ask yourself this when I have time to
learn how to weld if I had my own TV
show I can tell you right now the answer
is no and a lot of you [__] out there
will be like yeah but you had the
[__] money to tell somebody else to
do it well you know what I don't live my
life that way I don't I'd like to learn
how to do it yeah like uh three act uh
Academy Award winners in this movie
yeah what am I doing why would you go
back why would you go do TV movies are
great you do it it's it's we have you
from this day to this date and then it's
done right those other people like who
those people on one hour dramas are
shooting a movie that never ends right
and I get and it's a concept you're a
constant critic like you get the
one-time critic if it's a good movie
it's a bad movie it's been different
whatever that criticism comes in that
one stretch the TV show is constant
criticism
how hard they I don't want to work that
hard yeah I did an episode of new girl I
had a great [__] time but it was 14
hour days and they had been I I did it
in February it's a half hour show they
were doing 14-hour days and they had
been going since August
it's just like
I thought I worked hard and then I did
an episode of that show it's like dude I
am a bum and I love it that was Breaking
Bad coming back for sure they say
breaking but no I Better Call Saul is
coming back okay yeah it's coming back
any word on that you doing anything else
uh I have no idea I mean if if I did I
couldn't say that I was but but to be
honest with you I haven't heard anything
no
I haven't heard anything okay it's over
um all right uh Silverman props
good day sir
uh good day good sir sorry I saw your
name in the end credits
uh Slash thank you of Sarah Silverman's
latest comedy special special and was
curious if you had anything special to
do with the show love your comedy and
hope it never ends very good this guy
from Germany
Lars Germany uh once I noticed your name
in the end of the credits you know those
German guys they died but they read all
the way through you know they read all
the words because just in case there's
any like that's why they can make a
station wagon that goes zero to 60 in
[__] three and a half seconds any
hidden messages in there they're looking
for
um
yeah the uh that opening bit that she
did was she threw the the ball against
the wall
um I was down The Comedy Store like a
week before she did uh her stand-up
special and she was throwing a tennis
ball against the wall or whatever and
somehow we talked to her special I was
like you know that could be cool if
you're just sitting there throwing the
ball against the wall blah blah maybe
that's why she did it maybe she just
thinks I'm a swell guy I have no idea I
should have waited till she told that
probably for the search engine
optimization that's probably right yeah
what is that no you're like we know you
tag like things like Bill Burr anything
popular if you like to put anything on
we're like Bill Burr comma um you know
they all in tour so when people are
searching things like Bill Burr her
thing Mike
ah you kissed you kids with the [__]
internet SEO they call it search engine
optimization all right morbid obesity uh
dear badass Billy Burr I guess I'm
supposed to give you a nickname yeah
we're running out here people you guys
don't have to do that all right my
brother's been dating a morbidly obese
girl for two years now my parents are
disgusted by this ah Jesus this is
brutal this is brutal already my mother
actually cried when she first met her
Jesus Christ dude and I get [__] for fat
shaming
[__] out
she can't even fit in the house
I thought I raised you better
put on that break that
holy [__] dude that's [__] brutal
more importantly her health is clearly
in great danger at her weight
um it's likely she doesn't get to 40. my
brother's 120 pounds she's at least
twice his weight
I'd even say near 300 pounds what's a
good way to convey the fact that if no
one steps in
with the harsh reality she's going to
have a short life also she routinely
stumbles out of a Cheesecake Factory
uh um
oh Jesus Christ dude that's [__]
brutal first of all I feel bad for her I
hope she loses the weight because I get
[__] on this podcast
Jay because I make fun of fat people the
way I make fun of a lot of [__]
everything and everybody thinks that
like uh you know they don't think that
but they say that I've been joking
saying fat shaming works because I do it
to myself and all of that type of thing
look at me right I fat shamed myself at
the beginning of the year because I saw
a picture of us at the Rose Bowl and I
was like yeah you just go look at my
[__] I mean I don't know why I just
don't get how more people don't shame
themselves in the like shaming
themselves into getting well dude you at
one point you at one point were pushing
200 pounds yeah and you went to the
doctor and the guy said that 30 pounds
overweight yeah he was like technically
I could write you into or obese that's
why I was living in San Diego and I was
just like still had a real job and was
doing comedy coming up and you know I
had health insurance so he was like
listen I I with the job and he's like I
could technically
take the with your height with your
weight you could be obese but I'm not
going to write that in because it could
affect your insurance you know yeah
right so he goes just get oh what do you
do and I told I was that that's when I
was drinking a lot of soda I mean tons
of it right and that's what if there's
people out there I'm telling you drop
that if you're you know what you know
why she's waddling out of a Cheesecake
Factory because she had three freaking
sodas on top of whatever else she had I
bet and the diet's the worst he said my
doctor looked at me and said the word
diet is the biggest is travesty that the
Food and Drug Administration allows
because it doesn't mean anything
anything's a diet if you eat a cow
that's your diet I mean a Diet Coke just
doesn't mean it that it's any better for
you it ain't gonna make you it ain't
gonna make you lose weight make you gain
weight so that's the one thing that you
cut out soda or pop as you guys call it
pop I got off Pop I was drinking like he
was like geez how many are you drinking
I was like I was on a Diet Dr Peppers
man I was knocking back like three four
a day and then when I would go golfing I
would knock down you know six of per
nine I'd have like you know a classic
cup I'd go through six seven eight ten
Diet Dr Peppers Jesus Christ yeah I just
I thought I was refreshing myself you
know on its diet and it tastes good I
love that doctor okay it's diet
and then when I quit that March 10 March
1st 2010 I've only had like ginger ale
and club soda I've never had like the
high fructose and the colos and any of
that sugary [__] it's been yeah and you
took it all off and then so what else I
just put a bunch on uh like doing what
over the fall because just enjoying it
you know what I mean like we were you
know we had we were cooking a lot the
holidays I had that holiday party the
Rose Bowl I mean my birthday's on
October 30th right right so once my
birthday hits this will be the first
time Halloween candy the next day
Halloween candy and it goes it doesn't
stop it goes right into Thanksgiving and
then before I know it I'm a week after
New Year's and I'm 30 pounds heavier
than I was I love that you acknowledged
Halloween candy like you're still
trick-or-treating oh I mean my whole my
whole childhood I was born the day
before Halloween is this the weekend
apart and then when I turned old enough
to drink this will be because I quit the
drinking this year for an experiment
this will be I'm gonna turn 42 in
October 30th right this will be the
first time I have not had alcohol on my
birthday since I was 19. and I'm not
going to do it I'm not going to do it
this year I'm going to just I'm going to
live I'm going to walk I'm going to walk
through the day of my birthday and go
wow basically 23 years of straight
partying because it's always been a
party it's been like de LA's birthday
and it's Halloween we can mix them
together
there's been day I don't even know I was
amazed don't remember most of my
birthdays in the 20s my friends we were
just it was a Halloween week I was
dressed up just [__] just plowed uh
Jesus Christ I mean well do you know
what amazed me was you you you were on
the wagon from Rose Bowl right up till
we did the the Vegas that we made though
yeah but you were you so you were like
I'm drinking this weekend and I'm going
right back to being on the wagon which
is what I said and you were able to do
it I haven't yeah I haven't been able to
do it you had a nice look but you had
that part of the year for you was like
you just finished a special you know you
you knew you were coming with black and
white was coming out you had a lot of
there was a lot of reasons for you just
not to you've been good for or I mean
since you started that quit one year a
couple years ago
you've been you've been able to go and
get nice little stretches in I haven't
been able to I'm very I'm a very key
player let me tell you something the
longest I've gone without drinking on
this last run was I think I had just had
a real bad flu for like eight or nine
days that I didn't drink and then this
has been the longest of my life I mean
this has been since since I was a
teenager yeah you've drank like
basically three days this whole year
four days right yeah three days three
days this whole year that's awesome man
yeah yeah that's awesome I wish again
I'm not gonna have another drink I think
until the Rose Bowl I think that's I got
those [__] Miller highlights I just
have like one a day yeah but that's not
you know but you know what it is it's
right after you have it right right
after you have that first one yeah but
the thing is if you just wait five
minutes you just drink a water if you
force yourself to just grab a water or
whatever your body like stops craving it
and you level out and you actually just
had that one and you're able to do it
but the the
the thing is with food and all of that
[__] for the longest time I was like
it's not a drug it's not drug it is yeah
it is it's like whatever you just ate
you want [__] if it's bad for you yeah
that's how you know it's bad for you
because you just ate it now you want
more which doesn't make any sense
because if you eat a salad you never
think like oh dude I want another salad
you don't but later on if you're hungry
you're thinking food salad vegetables
but you're not thinking like [__] food
but like if you eat I've just found if I
eat like if I eat an apple or whatever I
don't crave another Apple if I eat a
handful of chips cookies alcohol soda or
any of that [__] that's bad salted sugar
you just like you [__] it's like you're
feening for it sugar I mean that's why
people are fat they can't get off the
sugar and when you can get off the sugar
and you can take it out and the only
sugar you get is the naturals like the
fruits and the vegetable sugars the
natural sugars your body isn't looking
at food like oh my God I want that your
body tells you when it wants food so
then what what does he tell this this
tells her to get off the sugar and it's
going to take a month and salt salt but
definitely sugar first get off the sugar
because sugar you have to match it if
you drink colas and if you eat lots of
bread and pastas that's all tons of
sugar in there and your body has to
match that it wants more sugar so if you
drink a bunch of coke then it wants the
sugar food so when this woman walks in
if you were in the house and you got a
yellow like oh my gosh
in the background going hey
get off I will get in her face and get
off the sugar wipe it out of here there
and your hat around backwards put the
whistle in my mouth listen kick dirt
over a cake
Ah that's hilarious what the [__] are
you looking at out there it's been all
day with this [__] this is hilarious no
I mean that's the thing you came in here
for one reason and what was that to eat
all of our cake
that's in our Weaver reference you came
in here to [__] us
a chance again tomorrow no I didn't know
that that umpire was so great like what
are you gonna do Earl lose another world
series I want more than I've lost not
World Series is games
all right
where are we going video uh bill this is
video isn't mine but I came across it on
YouTube I actually watched some it's the
evolution of Walter White
um somebody did like this great like 15
minute video where they go from the very
first episode and they just take like
the key scenes I watched like a minute
and a half of it before I was just
getting chills I'm like all right I got
one of the reasons why it's one of the
great shows of all time
um all right two girls
dear Bill I'm just some kid in high
school doesn't know Jack all about
dating but a week ago I learned that a
chick I knew
but didn't like had put me on her phone
as a wallpaper this apparently has been
going on for a year and I just learned
about it from one of her friends I knew
this chick liked me but I couldn't stand
her this is weird
he said I tried letting her down I tried
being a dick to her just to uh why can't
you just be honest you know what because
you're young just be like listen I know
you really like me but I'm not feeling
that way about you you say what's up
[__]
she just keeps acting like I am still
all hers yeah that would get annoying I
knew she was into me while I was still a
freshman but it was near summer so I
thought she would just forget all about
it
um and if that wasn't enough for friends
that told me this uh tried hitting on me
when she told me what as if this wasn't
enough her friend told me
this tried hitting on me dude you guys
gotta proofread this [__] exactly you
gotta let me tell you something if
you're in high school you're not going
to make it to College all right hang on
just keep talking like as I try to die
this guy whatever he's butchering it is
this a guy that's talking about a girl
with his phone
listen be happy listen big oh I got it I
got it yeah there's no comment as if
this wasn't enough her friend that told
me this
tried hitting on me when she told me
oh okay yeah see there was no
punctuation in there
um
okay so now the girl that tells you that
this girl's obsessed with you then hits
on you
okay first of all I just learned some
psycho had me on a wallpaper for a year
and I didn't know so the last thing I
wanted to think about is dating second
what a [__] move on a friend's part
hitting on a guy this guy's definitely
the glass is half full huh what the [__]
you got two women here I know dude and
it's have at it and it's like get you
hitting on a guy her friend has been
stalking Bill I'm ready to tell them to
both go go [__] themselves but what is
your opinion on this uh you ignore the
first girl you bang the second one and
then you get on with your life what do
you think Jay I think you uh I think you
you play them into each other I mean I
think that if these girls are friends
together and the other girls hitting on
you right I think you I think you I
think you are you going for the
three-way oh yeah man I'm going for I'm
going for the three-way early I'm going
to the whole get get together let's do
this as like a group and hang out you're
going on side kick play a little dumb
play a little dumb I'm on the whole I
don't know really everything about the
phone and I'm not the girl with the
phone I'm not gonna give up the fact
that I this other one was kind of
hitting on me I'm gonna let this all
come together and see where it goes Mad
Hatter he's eating grass yeah because
you know why they're they're the ones
you're they're bringing it to you
they're serving it to you on a platter I
mean they're literally you are you're
the you're the reason why this whole
thing is developing so let it let these
two kind of you know just sit back relax
all right so email lawhead's Court he'll
tell you how to tell you how to bring
them in this could be instrument Landing
here except my sleeve um all right fat
shaming goth daughter uh Billy burrito
what a good way to Fat shame us what's a
good way to Fat shame a sense why am I
becoming the fat chain person all right
you're like yeah I don't want to make
people feel bad about being fat I mean
I'm joking around about this [__] I want
people to be in shape so don't [__]
hang this thing around me uh I'm not
going to read that's two in one week
that'll be bad the next thing you know I
got some group
yeah you know I know it's jokes but it
sets a precedence there's a bunch of
people you know protesting in front of
you they're not gonna they're not gonna
because like that's another good reason
not to have a [__] security show he's
got people in scooters driving around
with us no but if you had a [__] TV
show then they actually give a [__]
about you because they can they can't
fire you from stand up or my podcast
they can't they could I guess they could
take away the advertising but I'd still
do it I don't give a [__] uh advice on
Friends hey Bill I'm uh I'm a junior a
junior in high school and I've got one
group of really good friends like eight
or nine people we are like the funny
guys of our school always giving each
other [__] well there's one friend and
he was an [__] for an entire summer
to my other friends who was a girl
that he liked a lot there you go that's
that's American public schools right
there
there's one well there's one for Jay
talk again tell these people it's
unbelievable it's just uh unfriended you
know get read a book uh
I mean all these auto corrects and
grammar checks on compute I mean how do
you not get out the right email that you
want with every bit of technology that
we have I I just I'm stunned okay I got
it I figured it out thank you okay so
there's well there's one friend and he
was an [__] for an entire summer to
my other friend who was a girl that he
liked a lot so this guy is friends with
this girl
and this other guy liked our lawn who's
being an [__] to her um okay he
started treating her like [__] when she
told him she didn't like him and while
things were heated all summer and it was
weird uh I was letting the girl know
that he was saying what I was letting
the girl know
what he was saying
and do to her
and now they are Jay talk again just
just talk to the people here I was
living I don't even know what he started
out by saying we got I got nine buddies
that are like the funny guys of the
group I was more interested in that like
I thought he was going to go somewhere
with like Hey we're doing the like I I
don't even know I mean he's just now
he's just like he's got basically hold
it down to three people he was saying
was this kid went over he ratted out the
girl he's saying this and that to the
other thing he said now this [__] guy
and this girl who's a friend are like
buddy buddy again because the other guy
said that the dude writing this letter
was lying and none of it was true
but of course she's going to believe the
other guy because she likes him this
guy's gonna reel her right in oh no she
doesn't he likes her
wow that's weird so why the [__] would
she believe that he basically got
everyone against me and I don't know
what to do this guy's a psycho
manipulating everyone he acts like he
doesn't say anything and he acts overtly
nice to me when he's around me yeah this
guy's a psycho and it pisses me off he
won't tell the truth to anyone so my
question is should I even try to fight
back against this and try to win back my
few close friends or should I just tell
them to go [__] themselves and try to
make new friends so you got ostracized
by everybody uh
um look who gives a [__] at this point
if she doesn't believe you then [__] her
let this guy do whatever the hell he
wants to do with her
um
it's gonna come back listen walk away
beat a bigger take the high road walk
away like that like that gun fighter in
the west Walking Away by himself and
this guy the other guy will end up doing
this to other people and he'll do it to
her
you are right she'll be like dude you
know but whatever this guy's name is
Johnny is you know hey man he's he's the
real deal and you know what you don't
need people like that in your life do
that early get used to that early
getting those kind of people no it is
dude I'm telling you learn learn how to
cut the weeds early man I tell you what
because as you get older you don't want
to get into those habits man it's just
like it's like you know does it like
Abused Women man they get into a habit
and I'm not comparing it's a little bit
but you know you don't want to get into
that habit of being walked on and
treated that way and just including
yourself in a group of friends because
you're con like oh I don't know what
else to do how will I get new friends
yeah dude no no and you gotta cut the
weeds you do dude I did I took me to 40
last five six years I cut out all the
negative people in my life and the level
of drama that just it was like a vacuum
it just got sucked right out of the room
and
um recently I was around I was just
doing some gig and I ended up just
getting in like this Social Circle of
just three or four people that were used
to be like the kinds of people I used to
[__] hang out with and uh I
immediately sensed like negative energy
which I had never felt before because I
was so used to it right I was like I I
was one of those guys my whole [__]
life I was just like you know when I
[__] get out of this house I'm gonna
do blah blah then you go out in the
world because that's all you know you
just recreate that whole [__] thing
over again that's totally what I did it
took me like 20 years to cut all of that
[__] out and uh there's also that that
I'm very forgiving of psychos I am a
psycho but I'm right because I'm a
temperamental Maniac for so many years
in my 20s and early 30s you know and it
is to be self-sufficient and just become
a complete [__] loner yeah that's
what you do it is you go out like that
[__] the hearse guy there look at the
house he had yeah exactly but that's
what that's true though you go out like
a gunfighter man and you just walk like
you know Shane man you just go go out
and ride ride out on these people
it's [__] hilarious right out um I
gotta read a couple of uh
I got to read a couple more advertising
things and I want to hear your opinions
on the first two weeks of uh two and a
half weeks because we're still in the
middle of football Sunday here oh by the
way we got we gotta talk about you you
[__] big day I'm jacked up man I
think we might have a football team in
our hands to answer that one guy's first
question on the fan mail dude Christ to
answer that one guy's first question on
a fan mail about why don't you do TV
well you know why he doesn't do
commercials yeah
isn't that the [__] truth that's a
read there
yeah that's that's some heavy duty uh I
like that that is the Dollar Shave Club
though that's a good even though I have
a beard and I grew that because I
literally grew my beard four years ago
because of the prices of razors I mean
I'm like
you know you you got to go they there's
two things that they lock up in the
store did you know that liquor and
razors I mean you gotta go get a guy
with a key yeah that's how and it's
always been it's always been a complete
rip-off I've never understood it and you
know what's funny drilling through these
things are they offshore drill for race
I mean the price of razors for what you
get is is when I grew the spirit it was
because
okay man I'm not do you remember do you
remember that late night they actually
had that sharpener that you could stick
your raid into which that thing came and
went in two seconds I bet the big race
companies it bombed or they just bought
it out yep they brought it out oh the
creator of it was in a diner was just
like all of a sudden they poisoned me
and [__] ran out and died yeah well
they probably just bought the patent to
it and then just you know kept it a lot
of people buy patents and then just hide
them from everybody so they can't
compete with them
I don't know wait let's talk Browns
before we get the [__] out of it we'll
get back up oh Jesus that dog pound
horse [__] sorry no grown man I never
liked it from the start but we have a we
actually have a dog now the first time
we have a dog that's cool like a real
dog I like that I like that names oh
good deal yeah we got a bull map Brown
bullmastiff named Swagger it's his first
year is the like so he kind of sits on
the sidelines and just kind of licks
himself I said Jesus Christ I said when
I first got him I go I just this dog you
know I don't know if this is a good
timing with the way our these this
thing's gonna this thing's gonna run out
in front of a car after week three
probably just [__] throw himself in
traffic on the on the uh did you guys
run what happened I was in one man so uh
you know we tried to give it away to New
Orleans we had a great first half and
then uh we just when you came in and
started doing a podcast we made we we
went like I just heard you yell yeah 87
yards well we didn't go all 87 yards but
we started I think on the 13 with about
two and a half minutes to go and Hoyer
took us down the field and we had a you
you know we we had a great catch on the
side Miles Austin had a great catch on
the sidelines at about the 39 to keep
the drive going and then we uh a big
defensive breakdown we hit a we hit a
receiver down the middle to the 10 with
four seconds to go and kind of Hit the
game winning field goal 26-24 Browns
over the Saints who a lot of people put
your Saints are going to be in that
[__] final four mix one and one and
we should be Pittsburgh we lost to
Pittsburgh don't the Saints have a
horrific defense or something well it
looked bad last week against Atlanta and
it it didn't look great against us today
well Rex Ryan or not Rex Ryan the fat
one and the the one that needs the one
that needs to get off the sugar the Ryan
oh is he fed I don't know the ugly rhyme
I want the Hat the hair yeah they look
the same don't they no well Rex went on
that lap band what's the guy's name Rob
Rob has one of those like just
disgusting stomachs that you know what I
mean like he's got like the skinny legs
the regular like neck and arms and then
he's just got one of those man pregnant
bellies it's disgusting it's disgusting
well you're one and one I want to hear
can I hear something positive from a
Cleveland Browns fan I like it I think
we got a good coach on our hands I said
even after the first loss and I'm
watching a little bit of this I just
tweeted out I go I think you know I
think we actually have a well coached
football team on our hands which we just
haven't had we just I mean we we just
haven't had a coach
right since we've come back as the brown
we haven't had a coach since Belichick
and now those are the guys that are the
last time we won a playoff game as the
Cleveland Browns who are now the
Baltimore Ravens but as LeBron yeah you
beat us we beat this we beat the Bill
Parcells Patriots in a wild card game at
Cleveland with Bill Belichick is our
head coach student became the master 20
years ago that's 20 seasons ago all
right well I'm a I'm a closet Cleveland
Browns fan so I hope you guys have a
great season uh I'm psyched the Patriots
won and we were like I got nervous after
that first drive
um but you know Adrian Peterson wasn't
there so
uh but I don't know we did do some
things but I don't know when I when I
saw Seattle on that first game and I
then watched the 49ers I'm just like
it's just so clear that the NFC you know
if everybody stays healthy that the
Super Bowl is gonna be out that way
again teams hadn't stopped playing from
last year I said after week one I'm like
they look like they're eight weeks in
dude P Karen's amazing I've never been
more wrong about that guy I was like
that guy I think he's you know he just
has like that nice guy look about him
when he coached the Patriots I was just
like this guy doesn't have it and then
even when he did well at uh uh USC I was
just like well you know he's not he's
not a [__] NFL coach someone who
never coached football I'm sitting there
saying this guy is not an NFL coach and
he won like two or three championships
well the crazy thing is is now the NFL
that was always the hit you couldn't be
a college could the college coach other
than Jimmy Johnson the college goddamn
Cowboys the college coach never came in
and did any anything in the NFL none of
them Nick Saban Lou Holtz none of them
Switzer Barry Swift that was Jimmy's
team that was come on that's uh but none
of them could do that but the trend has
changed change because football has
changed the quarterback in football has
changed to a college-style quarterback
so now you got Pete Carroll ultraly
successful Jim Harbaugh utterly
successful you got Chip Kelly now at the
Eagles turning that thing around real
quick so you're gonna see more turning
around the culture and the love yeah the
college coaches are successful now in
the NFL and you know what more so do
they give Johnny Manziel a chance no no
because he screwed the pooch on the side
of the [__] field there yeah you know
listen to Brian or Brian Hoyer looks
great and he knows the Playbook and the
team is playing for him and you try to
suggest that Johnny was not learning The
Playbook he he isn't where did you hear
that we heard that in uh some articles
that came out of training camp why he
was shooting himself in the foot because
they were giving him chances to win this
job even to Hoyer was the number one guy
patine was a new coach and he was giving
him a chance to win a job and in some of
the some of the Articles coming out of
cleveland.com it was saying that he was
not grasping the Playbook I think that
means he's not learning The Playbook or
you know know he's a I'll tell you this
kid has had every opportunity in the
world but if you're not going to sit
down and learn your X's and O's I mean
the team's not going to get behind you
and if that doesn't happen it is very
difficult to win in this league
look like these guys okay they will hurt
you
they are terrific in punt coverage and
they are it's an excellent creativity on
Fourth and law that's a hughie brown
doing football by the way there's not
one woman left that listens to this
podcast anymore this is just a sausage
fest I gotta [__] it I gotta I don't
think I've ever had a female guest have
I I don't think I ever had you're well
your wife
no no I mean like a like a [__]
outside of somebody I live with
um
have I had a female Comic-Con here I
guess I haven't
uh oh am I sexist all right this is it
everybody this is the end of the podcast
thank you so much for listening uh
congratulations to everybody's team one
this week uh you know it's only week two
don't get too down on your team if they
lost that's it go [__] yourselves and
I'll talk to you next week
[Music]
welcome back to the anything better NFL
Week number two for bet MGM guys uh we
are back we're excited about week two
had a good week one
um our partners bet MGM are back for the
22 season and we'll be using the best
lines out there which are the BET MGM
lines to make all of our picks you'll
have special offers uh for all of our
listeners each week if you haven't
signed up for bet MGM yet use bonus code
Burr that's b-u-r-r and you'll get a
hundred percent risk-free bet up to a
thousand on your first wager here's how
it works you go to the app you download
it you sign up using bonus code Burr
that's b-u-r-r you deposit at least 10
bucks place your first wager on any game
you'll receive up to a thousand dollars
in free bets if the BET even if the BET
loses just make sure you use bonus code
Bird that's b-u-r-r when you sign up
okay it's very simple
and uh you'll love it
oh here
um
what a week one it was what a week one
it was
Sneaky Pete that's that's what I'm
taking away from that Gino Smith looking
like uh Gotta Give him credit Gotta Give
him credit man he looked all right did
he [__] looked all right I didn't see
anything I'm I don't have any [__]
time I missed everything I literally saw
like a half a football I watched a half
of the Chargers versus the Raiders
and I'm going to tell you I don't like
the Chargers defense as much as they uh
had three picks
I just thought that there was just
massive chunks of yards being gained too
much in that that if they play a little
uh better team I don't know but their
offense looked fine
but
um you know they were up big and then
they just kind of let them come back
I don't know but I'm also sitting there
going like is that what the [__] NF
that's kind of what the NFL is now
um yeah they were saying yeah they were
saying that like all of the starters
didn't play in the preseason game and
some of these games look like preseason
but I'll tell you what I don't want to
sound repetitive because I did uh good
morning Football on the NFL Network
yesterday I had a great time Andrew you
could throw a clip up on that could have
also Tom Brady I gotta talk I gotta say
Tom Brady dude it's it's getting to the
point where it's like weird it's like
he's in here like this is like yeah it's
he's amazing they look like they can
keep winning
um but he's got to stop too he's got
when is it enough like I'll be honest
he's the first athlete where like I kind
of like agree with his wife I'm like
just enough
I I actually agree with it it's like
just like if I I would be like if that
was me I would expect my wife to sit
down and go this is a problem we need
help we need help here this is a this is
a serious issue here you have to stop
Tom we know you're good yeah I mean is
it going to be 14 Super Bowls before you
look in the mirror and go maybe it's
enough I had a good time but we were
talking about the emotional roller
coaster that was my living room during
that game 13-nothing you know my son is
sitting there he's kind of like you know
we're watching uh Daniel Jones not
really get protected but then saquan
makes that big run and we're like all
right all right he looked all right he
stayed in bounds and then he had another
run and we started going nuts but um you
know going for it with um going for it
to win the game it was it was pretty
cool to finally get a win
um oh and Andrew do you have the um do
you have that thing of the guy running
out the so Bill this is a um
this is a video of a New York football
Giants fan running out of his front door
and after the football Giants what they
moved to the the baseball Giants moved
[__] 50 60 years ago
that's why I always say because Chris
Berman brought it back and people keep
going the New York football Giants I
don't know why I do it but this this
apparently this kid because apparently
the Giants haven't won week one since
2015. I believe he's tell me he was
speaking no he didn't streak but he just
went out it almost looked like he was
upset still no right here
holy
thanks bye guys
we finally went and open oh my God
dude I I don't know whether to be like
he screamed like finally won an opener I
didn't even know that they didn't win an
opener for that many years that's how
nuts in tune that guy is
it's week one dude he ran out the door
like we won the NFC championship
I didn't see one second or any highlight
of the Patriots either I missed
I'm missing everything dude I just spent
out here on tour so I I saw until the
first quarter of uh Seattle
first Denver dude everything that I
thought was gonna happen didn't happen I
thought yeah I'm like the Chiefs
notoriously start out slowly [__]
destroyed
Arizona I knew the Jets
you know Ravens that one seemed like
that was a I had a good shot at that one
I don't even know what the [__] I won
um nah dude it's week one it's a long
season
I know you walked around your house
talking [__] I did not no I I actually
walked around the house going why are
the Cults losing to the Texans
um dude did you hear what the Broncos
head coach said he goes yeah we probably
should the Broncos head coach
takes to this actually a really big
mistake he takes the ball out of Russell
Wilson's hands on Fourth and five and
decides to kick a 64-yard field goal
which there's been one or two so it's
Fourth and five and he wants to get out
of Seattle with the win so he says
Russell you're not gonna go for we're
taking the ball of hands we're gonna try
to kick a record-breaking thing in
Seattle it misses and then the next day
he goes yeah we probably should have
went for it so you took the ball out of
Russell Wilson's hands in that moment
against his old team and uh yeah it was
a [__] story punts it
no he couldn't punt it it was it was the
it was there was like there was the end
of the game
it was fourth and five with like 20
seconds left not even
okay and it's a tie score
no they're down one
they're down one so they need a field
goal but if you get he had two timeouts
if you get fourth and five it's a doable
field goal so and he had a down left oh
I see what they're saying you know so
here we go guys we are ready for our
picks for week number two I believe I go
for go first you go first Paul I go
first this week man oh a lot of high
spreads bill there's a lot of tens eight
and a halfs and sevens and seven and a
half this week yeah
um all right oh this is all of them
thank you Andrew I like I like it
looking like this here
um I'm not touching the game tonight
Chargers and Chiefs I'm not touching
that [__] game
touching that one oh dude that I'll see
you know that is a [__] start the
backyard fire game dude that's a fun one
that's it I think I think that one you
go the over
yeah I think that one's gonna live up to
the height and that one goes to you over
I don't you know
I think uh
dude I don't know what do you think a
pissed off Patrick Mahomes I didn't see
that coming everyone else was going on
that Russell Wilson in Denver and
[__] uh
who the [__] was that that was wave I
think
I think that Mahomes heard people saying
he can't do it without Tyreek Hill and
then he [__] put 44 I'm good good on
him but I'm gonna go my first pick this
week
uh I gotta see if they're for real it's
one of those I gotta see it and they got
off to a better second half and came
back to end up tying the Texans
they're playing at Jacksonville and
Jacksonville still has to prove they
could win with this new guy I'm going to
take the Indianapolis Colts given four
on the road riding that horse he lost
his only loss yeah I'm riding that horse
I like that I like that you know what
I'm going to take Paul I'm gonna take
the [__] Chicago Bears
that's a great one I think it's the
division rivalry they're always close
they got a good [__] defense and I
think the big secret about your Green
Bay Packers is the only piece they
[__] have is Aaron Rodgers and that's
why he's been [__] pissed off every
year he's got no one to throw too
I don't think they don't have any
excitement up there they have Aaron
Rodgers standing up there like what when
the [__] the calvary coming
so I know they lost everybody's probably
thinking they're going to come out all
pissed off I don't think they do I also
there's a big part of me think I just
took my first loss of the week it's
gonna be a tough season Paul
I can already feel it public clouds the
walls are closing in after week one
I actually I actually think you just
nailed it I think Aaron Rodgers doesn't
have the team that he needs 10 points is
a lot
Island but he's gonna win the thing I
think they're gonna win it's just a
matter of the 10 points I'm gonna go the
other way for my next pick okay
I'm gonna take
the defending Super Bowl champions given
10 at home after that loss they had on
opening night to the bills I think that
uh they're gonna come out and beat
um beat the Atlanta Falcons so I'm gonna
I'm gonna take
the Rams give in 10. I don't mind that
at all they're at home
yeah
oh that's subversy that's the Versi a
road to good road team a good home team
coming off a loss on the road no but
they were home last week too they were
home against the bills but yeah I'm
stupid I'm stupid Paul I don't know
anything that's going on in the world
right now uh
um all right next
I thought I had my next one right in the
shoot
um I'm gonna take uh
oh am I gonna do this am I gonna do this
I need a win here and I gotta go I gotta
go with my gut
I'm taking the Pittsburgh Steelers
giving two to the Patriots
I think we're gonna I think we're gonna
start slow they're in Pittsburgh
um
we've historically but Bill Belichick
going up against Mitch trubitsky but
it's only two
because I think this is going to be a
close game
and I think that they're going to win it
in the end and the Steelers should do
Paul we've beaten the [__] Steelers
you know for the last three presidents
you know what I mean I feel like the
Steelers that do
I'm taking the Steelers and that's great
then I can sit down and root for my
Patriots and if they [__] win I'm
happy and if they lose you know I get a
victory okay you know what that's that's
a nice stair that's a nice defense
mechanism for the emotions
I mean what am I gonna do I mean
we're not good right now Paul we're not
a good team we're not a bad team I think
we're good we're going to be like uh uh
we're gonna be an 8-9 team not the old
eight Nate anymore a nine and eight
eight and eight and nineteen
all right I mean still I I think you're
gonna find out who teams are by week
five but I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do this because I'm going to
the game and I can't go to see my New
York football Giants play the Carolina
Panthers after that win and be there
with my family and not say that they're
going to win the game by by uh three so
I'm gonna take the New York Giants lay
in two
Point favorites at home because I'm at
the game with my family
uh can we beat Baker Mayfield by a field
goal in our building after that
emotional win I say yes
all right let me I I'm like doubles
advocate here
all right how's your defense
defense is what held Us in that game
okay I like that answer
Baker Mayfield versus the ivory kid
I like that I like that I feel bad
betting against my team but you know
this is uh this is money here Paul
all right
this is Big Boy time you know I don't
think you're getting the job done I
don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__] stalling for my next
one
um
oh [__] it I'm taking Patrick Mahomes
and the Chiefs tonight
Chiefs put a little [__] foot in the
Chargers asses and say guess whose
division this still is oh we are at home
I think it's gonna be about uh four and
a half God they picked the perfect
number don't they Paul
worst case scenario Paul I get my first
loss of the week out of the way early
um bill I gotta be honest with you
you're going you you are you this is a
bold week for you I like it though
I like steel is it getting to what am I
talking about my my last pick of the
week yeah man this is dude I I feel like
I could be this is a tough week too man
um all these 10 point spreads
you know I was thinking about the Lions
but I don't know dude they're I just
don't know who they are I don't know I
don't know [__] about either one of them
who are they playing because I looked at
that game I was like I don't know [__]
about the Lions or whatever the [__]
they're playing they're playing the
Washington they're playing Washington
commanders and commanders
look at Vegas doesn't know
point to happen that's that's a pick and
pull is is Geno Smith gonna all right
dude I I mean you know smithson's in
Seattle no I know you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do it do it Paul
I think this is you I think you go back
to back
I'm gonna take
the two-point dog Minnesota Vikings you
[__]
in Philly
wow two points I just like this
Jefferson kid
I love that pick
which could be a warning to you yeah but
Philly looks good too
huh Philly looked good dude and they're
home
and they're the Vikings and the Vikings
have the curse too don't ever forget
that all NFC east teams won except the
boys nobody knows this but the Vikings
are a cursed franchise
is that right yeah they were supposed to
be an AFL team and then [__] the NFL
goes hey you want to join us
and they said yeah they walked out on Al
Davis and all those cowboys
oh man they all got together and said
yeah [__] the NFL we're taking them down
and at the 12th hour
the NFL said the Vikings you want to
join the NFL and they said yeah and they
walked away oh Paul you can't do that
uh you can't do that
the Minnesota Vikings they're dead to
the football gods
um
here's my thing the Buffalo Bills okay
when you got that [__] Maniac running
for the Tennessee Titans is their
defense good enough
I do love Josh Allen but I do respect
what's their running back's name Paul I
got I don't know anybody's name anymore
Derek Henry Derek I mean I'm not [__]
I'm not laying 10 points with that
[__] coming at [__] that
that's just that you know what that is
Paul you know what that is right there
that's crazy talk I'm staying away from
that game that's lunacy that is lunacy
I would take the Bengals seven and a
half if they were home I don't like I
don't like in Dallas
I don't like that game I don't like
anything else that I see
I Gotta Feeling the Saints are gonna
beat the Buccaneers Paul what do you
think about that I was just looking at
that I was just looking at it I got a
feeling
what the Cleveland Browns do last week
Paul
you know what I they I think they won
day one right Andrew did they win I
didn't see it
wait who did they play last week
oh they played the Ravens the Jets did I
mean
hey what happened week one
you know what [__] that I'm gonna take
the Ravens again [__] the Dolphins
oh
ready to take the Ravens I like the rigs
huh is that what the Browns beat the
Panthers 26-24
away 26 24. who's that quarterback
[__] uh Jerk Joint Johnson what's his
name there is he back yet or is he still
on suspension no he's suspended for 11
games dude
11 games did he get 11 hand jobs is that
why was it one game per hand job I think
he got like 24.
good job
this is the kind of male toxicity we
need to get away from
dude I gotta be honest with you your
Kansas City Chiefs pick tonight is
really [__] ballsy and I almost want
as much as we're going head to head I
almost want to see that win because of
the balls bill you went for the
two-point conversion to win a game I
love it
it's a ballsy call
what's the two-point conversion
oh because of the spread no no no
because the because the Giants did it at
the end I'm just I was just saying it's
a I I think it's a great all right we're
taking too long here what are the what
are the what are the Browns do okay they
won last week okay we already answered
that ah
against the hapless Jets oh they look
bad wait the brown speed who
they beat the Carolina Panthers by two
and the Carolina Panthers are dogs this
week against the Giants by two
Giants won last week
Jets got smoked
ah the problems don't win two Geeks in a
row the Ravens do I'm gonna go with the
[__] no you know what am I gonna do the
Saints oh when them saints
come marching in uh no because you know
what Brady has a running game that's
scary yep
the Saints always play him good you know
I don't know [__] about that division
I'm gonna shut my [__] freckled Yap
and I'm gonna stick with it I'm going
with the Ravens oh Paul I mean when a
guy's waffling the way I'm waffling on
this last one
I'm like a corned corned gambler
but you got in the corner of the casino
you don't know what I'm gonna bet on
Ravens laying three and a half let's see
here I got two favorites
and I got two dogs
all right that's good that's a little
more even out
all right so
here we go we're still we're up on the
book Paul thanks to you yeah bill has
for all of us
yep bill has the Chiefs dude we both I
started one and three last year dude
there's a lot of time but Bill has the
Chiefs the Ravens the Steelers and the
Bears yeah but Bill isn't watching any
football this is the difference this is
housewife bill I got to get out from
underneath all of this [__] work see
there's a river right out there Paul
right now and the amount of times I
thought of just jumping in it during the
course of my [__] day I'm almost done
dude this thing is [__] locked next
week and then I can go back to being the
Meathead that I am watching the sports
uh and I have the Colts the Giants the
Rams and the Vikings there you have it
those are our picks I hope we uh I hope
we won you some money last week is the
Gambler no one wants to gamble against
right now no no no don't do that to me
don't do that I'm sorry I thought you
liked the hype no no no it's it's way
too early it's way too early
humble Paul verzie an older wiser Paul
verzi yeah this is not talk [__] about
the book when the 17 weeks to go yeah if
this was me this guy if this one's gone
underdogs yes not the Paul verzie
that you first you went down to the CFL
they sent you down to the CFL of
gambling and you learned some things
ah you gambled on the Edmonton Eskimos
and you came back and you get better at
this [__] than I am though if this was
the me that if this was the me that met
you the first couple years we met oh I'd
be but nah dude I I I've learned I've
learned oh dude you be laying
collectively 40 points on those [__]
picks dude look where I'm staying right
now
where you staying the Watergate Hotel oh
oh wow it's downstairs in the steam room
no
[Laughter]
let the Monday night special
and win some money for you
[__] money for you how did we do last
week we didn't hit it we hit the under
right we hit two we hit two of the three
but Bill we have two Monday night games
so we have to pick one that we want to
do there's two Monday night games uh
this week There's the Titans and bills
and there's the Vikings and Eagles so
which one do you want to go with before
we pick
foreign
s are extremely different
oh man these are tough games all right
let's go bills all right
grebel's still coaching them right
yeah
coaching tree as far as at least he was
played underneath him and I think he if
he learned anything working with Bill
Belichick it's how it's how to shut down
a high-powered offense with the
Superstar quarterback
oh so we're gonna take the Titan we're
gonna start with 10 points
I don't know
Derek Henry mad about that loss last
week's a little overrated
gonna come walking in there their back's
all sore for breaking those tables and
all of a sudden they get a little
[__] nightmare coming at him
oh
you know what I don't know I hate these
games Paul it's early on so let's just
go with that guts
what's your guts say with the bills
dude you got me thinking that you you
changed my mind but now I like it where
it's like Tennessee's coming off a loss
they they don't want to go oh and two
Derrick Henry gonna got rocked against
the Giants people were talking that they
might not be as good this year
I think they lose the game but you want
to take the 10 points let's take the 10
points
hey who are we hey Paul you know I'm
just I'm just a guy eating wings you
know I'm just leaving the bills but just
doesn't think they're gonna win by 10.
all right you know what let's start the
game with 10 points start the game with
10 points Paul okay
uh I think that you know I think this
game's gonna be Paul I think it's gonna
be surprising
okay good I like what I think I think
that I think Tennessee's gonna [__]
hang with them
uh and I don't think it's gonna be a
defensive struggle
how about this how about the titans of
the over
[Music]
okay okay I like that a little loopy
here Paulie didn't get enough sleep last
night I'm a little jet-lagged okay so
let's do that I like that and then we
can root for some point hey and how
about Josh Allen rushes for one that
[__] John Wayne and with with
football cleats on I say he gets one he
yeah we have to be distinct though rush
or or throw right he rushes
he runs in like a [__] man
he runs in like an atheist Tim Tebow
so he scores the touchdown and we don't
have to watch him pray afterwards
you know what you just took over this
Monday night special and I actually like
everyone you picked okay well remember
that when I drive it into the ground all
right you know what you can do the other
one then Paul no no no we can only do
one this week no I was I like I like it
I like it I like the 10 points in our
pocket I like rooting for points so we
need 49 points and Josh Allen to run one
um
I think he's definitely going to throw
one but we get better odds if he runs
one right Andrew
okay all right yeah I mean him throwing
it to digs I mean you probably make
[__] one dollar for every 100 you bet
well there it is guys
he's gonna do that with if 10 guys are
grabbing him and he just sticks the
[__] ball out
yeah
no I like it I like those fans with the
Z cavarici zebra [__] pants have been
going gonna be going nuts
piston quartz light right down their
[__] legs and excitement I think
that's that's what I think is going to
happen and you know what Bill we've
never went into a Monday night special
getting 10. so I'm kind of I kind of
like that first I don't know how much
we're gonna like it in the second
quarter but to start I think we're gonna
be pretty excited and we got a little
leg room
we got a little leg room to start the
game
that's all right that's all right it's
only a field goal
[Laughter]
they'll settle down Paul they're going
to settle down bill it's 13 nothing we
only need four we start to start doing
that looks like we're only down by three
Paul
I know they haven't done anything but
they're going to make their adjustments
I know he's throwing my favorite picks
and daughter the third quarter what are
they doing
oh you're gonna get a text message I'll
tell you right now he did not have them
ready to play tonight
Bill I know Derrick Henry got hurt in
the first quarter and tana what's his
name Tatum by almost a tattoo Tannehill
threw four pigs but he's due he's
[__] dude he's he's a fourth quarter
player
disrespected what do you think about
that how many times do they make lists
and he's never on it
just because people can't pronounce his
last name doesn't mean he can't get the
job done on a Monday night
for a couple of [__] bald bastards he
can do you ever see you guys last name
and go nah he's not gonna
ever see a guy looks like a football
player and then he takes the helmet off
you're like what in the is that a real
estate agent
dude I've
I've literally looked at a last name and
go nah he's not Hall of Famer
well then number yeah what was that
466 in the Hall of Fame
well there you have it everybody those
are our picks for week two hope you guys
enjoy it you got the Monday night
special Monday night special go to
bedmgm.com you're getting 10 points you
need Josh Allen to run one and you need
uh 49 points and you are a winner you
are a winner so go uh like we said sign
up to the best uh the best odds the best
lines out there to bet MGM uh all you
got to do is you got to download the app
you got to use bonus code Burr b-u-r-r
you put a betting up to ten dollars and
you'll get a thousand dollars in betting
for free what else can they do besides
give you the winner I mean that's all
they're not all bet MGM is not doing is
just giving you the winner but that's
for you to do they're giving you the
money to do it enjoy yourself bet
responsibly and uh enjoy week two of
football good time and remember guys to
bet you got to be 21 years of age or
older to wager in Arizona Colorado DC
Iowa Indiana Kansas Michigan Mississippi
New Jersey New York Nevada Pennsylvania
Tennessee
Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming only
new customer offer paid in free bets
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4700 for Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]